pink and her daughter willow actually
sing on the upcoming reimagined
soundtrack this is something that the
movie star Hugh Jackman says is his
million dreams come true that we're
really touched by the movie and it meant
a lot to them and the fact that they
reached out and asked to do this and the
willow actually saying I am into the
worlds of been so good I teared up when
I saw that video for the first time Hugh
was loving every minute of the
mother-daughter duet but who teaches to
sing with if he had the chance
there's no way I'm splitting those two
we caught up with the greatest showman
at the New York premiere of his new
movie the frontrunner based on the true
story of former u.s. senator Gary Hart
whose 1988 bid for the presidency was
cut short amid reports of an
extramarital affair there's gonna be a
story tomorrow about me I was a
backpacker going around Europe with a
bunch of Aussie mates I don't remember
anything about it but it's a movie about
starting conversations having real
conversation there's no heroes no
villains in this movie it's it's a fun
ride always a front-runner in our book
Hugh recently celebrated his 50th
birthday with a big bash it was the best
50th party I've ever had now it was the
best party honestly it was amazing I'm
working only six year I was fine with
gift until I just heard that
[Music]